Okay.
So I told you at the start of this week that
if the recent polling trends continued, uh,
by the end of this week, or maybe by early
next week, Joe Biden could be out of first
place in the Democratic primary.
Bernie Sanders could be all the way down to
fourth place.
That was if the recent trends continued and
they have not.
Okay.
The trends have reversed.
Both Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders have recovered
a little bit of that support that they've
recently lost in the last 10 to 14 days or
so.
Uh, both Camilla Harris and Elizabeth Warren
who had been the big gainers since the, uh,
over the last 10 days or since the democratic
debate have leveled off.
So as of now, Joe Biden is still in first
place, although certainly by a smaller margin
than he has been.
Bernie Sanders is back into second place,
but just, just, just barely while Camila Harris
and Elizabeth Warren are sort of steady in
third and fourth places respectively.
Now what I want to deal with today is I want
to think about if and when should the candidates
poling under 1% abandoned the race if and
when should the candidates polling under 2%
get out of this race?
Uh, there are lots of them.
Okay.
According to the real clear politics average
of recent polls, there are currently nine
candidates polling under 1% those are Delaney,
Tim Ryan, Marianne Williamson, Kirsten Gillibrand,
Bennett and Hickenlooper build a Blasio, Jay
Inslee and Bullock nine candidates currently
polling under 1% now you'll notice that Eric
Swalwell is not on the list.
He was at the debate a week or two ago, but
he ended his presidential run earlier this
week.
Recognizing he's getting absolutely no traction
whatsoever.
Something.
Some of the others, it's unclear whether they
recognize or not or at least it's unclear
whether they care.
So that's the nine under 1%.
In addition, there are four more candidates
polling between one and 2%.
Those are Amy Klobuchar, Andrew Yang, who
Leanne Castro and Tulsi Gabard, and then just
just just barely eking out.
2% are Cory booker at 2.1 and Bedo O'Rourke
with 2.6 now, a few thoughts about this before
we move on and really dig into what is it
that these candidates should be doing.
It's kind of a tragedy that Beta is ahead
of Julio Castro.
Beta imploded in the presidential debate in
the Democratic primary debate a couple of
weeks ago.
Julio on Castro was actually quite strong,
but Beta was still slightly ahead.
That's unfortunate.
Uh, number two, similarly, Amy Klobuchar was
a train wreck in that first debate while Kirsten
Gillibrand actually did pretty well.
I don't agree with her on all policy, but
just in evaluating debate, performance, Dillard
brand did significantly better than Klobuchar.
Clovis are somehow ahead of Gillette brand.
But again, this is all like they're all polling,
so they're kind of all within the margin of
error in a sense.
So the immediate question is how long should
these candidates stay in the race?
I am four more candidates.
I am for more choices.
I'm for a more debate and more dialogue and
different ideas as part of the primary process.
But I also want there to be more depth in
the debates.
That can't happen when you have 20 candidates
across two stages and 32nd rebuttals as the
standard format.
Okay, so I, I do believe that we would in
many ways benefit from starting to trim the
field down.
We pulled our audience on youtube at youtube.com/the
David Pakman show.
Slash.
Community.
The question was who should exit the Democratic
primary before the next debates?
At the end of this month, 7% of our audience
say everybody should stay in 48% want everyone
pulling under 5% to get out, which is very
harsh.
A 22% say everybody under 2% should get out
and 15% say everyone under 1% should get out.
Now, just as a thought experiment, if everybody
under 5% got out today, that would leave only
five candidates and that includes p booted
judge at exactly 5% and not a fraction more.
It seems a bit aggressive to me at this point
in time.
We're still about a year out from the convention,
but certainly if you're still under 1% at
this point in time, you have no shot.
I would get out.
I think that the two percenters could make
the case for staying in to the second debate.
There's a good chance they'll be eliminated
by the requirements before the third debate
on September 12th and 13 to anyway, the next
debate is at the end of this month, July 30
and 31 on CNN.
A lot of these, you know, the, the two percenters,
many of them are going to be gone before the
third debate anyway because they're simply
not going to qualify.
So, uh, as a reminder to make that early September
3rd debate, candidates need to have both at
least 2% in four different polls and 130,000
unique donors as of right now, only Joe Biden,
Kamala Harris, Bernie Sanders, uh, Elizabeth
Warren and Pete Buddha judge have met that
criteria.
So this race will be effectively smaller by
September 12th.
Even if a lot of these candidates stay in,
they're not going to be on that third debate
stage until, unless things change radically.
Um, and potentially we will be down to just
one debate stage by September 12th instead
of having to do it on two nights.
So let me know what you think our audience,
at least on Youtube, an unscientific reflection
merely of the fraction of our nearly 700,000
youtube subscribers who chose to vote in this
poll.
Say if you're under 5%, you should get out
immediately.
That seems a little bit aggressive, but a
lot of these folks will be gone by September
12th let me know what you think.
Uh, I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is Twitter at David Pakman
show and voting is still open on the David
Pakman show youtube channel.
If you want to cast your vote, the David Pakman
show